c'est un matin où le froid est mordant
en beauce dans ce centre commercial de
sainte marie les boutiques ne sont pas
encore ouvertes mais dans les corridors
les discussions vont bon train
clermont va ramasser
strasbourg
faute de pouvoir tenir de rassemblements
c'est ici que le chef du parti
conservateur du québec éric duhaime
rencontre pour la première fois la toute
nouvelle association locale du parti
dans la circonscription de beauce-nord
sebo bravo merci vous êtes le quelques
heures plus tard le scénario se répète
cette fois dans un restaurant de la
circonscription de beauce sud toujours
une fan de mener en blouson sans toucher
nous attendent et consorts va pas en
quelques mois le parti parvenu à former
des associations dans 105 des 125
circonscriptions du québec en beauce
chacune d'elles compte plus de 1000
morts je travaille parce qu'on majorité
des petites municipalités avant
représentant le maire de saint-georges
connaît bien les électeurs et les
organisateurs politiques de la beauce
cet ancien député de l'année qu constate
que l'aiguillé politiques commencent à
bouger ça peut être intéressant au parti
libéral l'organisation se passe qu'est
pas mal à terre même à la cac
l'organisation ce que je sens dit non
que j'aie eue attendu je sais qu'il
travaillait pour le lac avant et ça se
vérifie dans les rangs conservateurs à
en croire l'aveu de ce membre à son chef
des mamans cac le support ne veut plus
rien savoir de la caq
sinon un peu plus
pour l'instant c'est essentiellement la
bataille pour l'abolition des mesures
sanitaires qui rassemble ses militants
sous l'ancienne conservatrice pour cette
élection va être différente un peu parce
que conseille très fortement les coeurs
et aigus puis je pense que ça s'est
développé un ainsi qu'est si le parti
peut compter sur des cac est déçu il en
va autrement de l'appui des militants du
parti conservateur du canada
même si sur la scène fédérale de maxime
bernier à richard lehoux les
conservateurs règne sur la bosse depuis
plus de 15 ans cet organisateur de
campagne prend ses distances je veux
aucune alliance plus aucune relation
appelé de l'eau ce qui est con
sommateurs fédéral c'est pas les mêmes
valeurs tafer il met en garde ceux qui
seraient séduits par le discours anti
mesures sanitaires tout le monde et
année la parade et me oui de l'eau à se
réfugier rapidement dans un parti juste
part des frustrations encore une fois le
lendemain de la pandémie on voit où on
s'en va on a encore des projets ça à
table a réalisé
faut pas juste que ça soit hier un feu
de paille monsieur duhaime et son parti
profite énormément du contexte actuel
les sondages démontrent que la beauce
n'est pas un phénomène isolé on remarque
que c'est dans la grande région de
québec que les appuis du pcq sont le
plus élevé on va regarder plus
particulièrement les couronnes de québec
et les circonscriptions sur la rive sud
de québec on parle de lévis et chutes de
la chaudière
si l'engouement semble se limiter à
quelques circonscriptions les électeurs
conservateurs eux sont dispersés à
travers tout le québec exception faite
de montréal l'électorat est un peu plus
jeune que la moyenne il est majoritaire
marolles ils habitent sur dans les
banlieues ou dans les régions du québec
si je suis monsieur legault je
surveillerai quelques circonscriptions
au québec parce que ça pourrait
certainement venir brouiller les cartes
de retour en beauce éric duhaime lui
rêve de victoire avec ses militants le 3
octobre au soir quand ils ont commencé à
annoncer des victoires vous soyez parmi
les premiers à huit mois de l'élection
bien malin celui qui peut prédire à
quelle position les conservateurs
québécois franchiront la ligne d'arrivée
ou même s'ils seront véritablement de la
course ici valérie gamache radio-canada
saint jean en bon